Speaker 1: Let's go next to let's go to Dave
from Brooklyn.
Dave, you were on the air.
Speaker 3: Hey, David, how are you doing today?
I'm doing well.
First thing I want to thank you, because every
day on my drive home from work, I listen to
you on YouTube and gets me through the.
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
Because I live in New York City commute, I'm
a high school teacher in the Bronx, and I
was wanted to get your opinion about something
because I have been.
Frustrated for a few years now about the lack
of progress that comes from the Democratic
Party, as far as you know, I'm a liberal minded
person, but I don't identify as a Democrat
anymore because we keep I don't want to say
losing is the wrong word, but we keep.
Failing to pass meaningful progressive legislation,
and I think a lot of it is due to complacency,
which I think comes back to something you
talk about a lot, which is lack of systematical
skills.
And I wanted your opinion on I see that as
a desire on both sides.
And I just feel that because on the left,
we get fed more accurate information.
And our media sources are generally more honest.
Therefore, it doesn't get shown as much as
it does on the right.
But I feel and this is what I want your opinion
on that because of our failing education system
and a lot of ways we don't have on the left,
we also lack a lot of those mixed martial
skills.
And I'm afraid that in the future that may
come to come to the forefront in a way that's
more meaningful than it does right now.
Because on the left, on the right, on the
right, obviously, it has come to the forefront.
Speaker 1: So I think that you're not wrong
that the left sucker suckers, the left suffers
from a lack of epistemological skills, too,
to some degree.
I don't think that's actually the source of
the left being ineffective in the United States.
I think it's actually a lack of rhetorical
skill.
I think it's it's and George Lakoff has written
about this a lot.
Thomas Frank has talked about this a lot.
We on the left, when you actually sit down
and explain to people not with a one line
slogan like if you think about the one line
slogans on abortion, right, hey, the right
is pro-life.
Anything other than that is anti life.
That's really effective.
If you just go with a one liner, when you
really sit down with people and you explain
stuff to them, whether it's about, you know,
10 years ago when you really talked in detail
about gay marriage or you talk about health
care now or whatever the case may be, the
country is much more on the left than the
representatives that we elect.
So what's the problem?
I don't think it's lack of a epistemological
skill.
I think it's lack of rhetorical skill by the
left combined with and this is the other part
that's important.
Lack of a willingness to sort of just like
power through the way that the right does
it, I mean, what Mitch Mitch McConnell, I
find to be a vile and immoral person, but
he's essentially a Republican hero, not only
for what he's been able to get done for Republicans
over the last decade, but what he's been able
to stop Democrats from doing.
Like, if you're a Republican, you've got to
love Mitch McConnell for what he's been able
to do.
So I think that the deficits for the Democrats
are twofold.
One lack of rhetorical skill in talking about
these issues in ways that connect with voters
more.
And number two, sort of a lack of willingness
to I'm not saying go low in like commit crimes
and do immoral things, but like get down and
really use whatever legal legal methods we
can use to actually get things done.
I think those are the issues.
Speaker 3: A very short while.
Yeah, of course.
So if I'm understanding correctly, so I heard
you talk about a couple of days ago on your
show when you were talking about you're showing
clips of some from sports.
Yeah.
And they were talking about getting out of
doing local local activism.
Right.
I'm wondering, you know, it was what you're
talking about related in any way to like the
affect long term effects of gerrymandering
and the drug war and local local voter populations
and all that kind of stuff?
Because that seems to be a place where maybe
in the long run, Democrats can improve.
Speaker 1: Absolutely.
And I guess that would be the third piece,
which is the right is just better at local
politics than the left.
It sucks that that's the case.
But they're just and by better, I don't mean
they're like inherently better.
I don't mean they're smarter.
They're just doing it.
They're they're carrying it out in a more
effective way.
And that includes school boards, PTA, city
councilors, et cetera.
Yeah, the Democrats.
I'm not a Democrat either.
I don't really care about the Democratic Party
as a party to the extent that we can get some
progressive things done through the Democratic
Party.
Great.
But I don't find it to be a remotely competent
political party.
Speaker 3: Thank you so much.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
All right.
Wow, excellent.
The these callers are basically as good as
the guests we were going to have, so I really
can't complain.